just recently i saw the trailer for tmnt
shredders generic title but it's a
cheesy 80s action figure show so i'll
give it a pass
i have to say i'm impressed with what
i've seen a modern take on the classic
beat-em-up turtles and time
i'll play a lot of games from around
that era but this one was an exception
and much like the 80s turtles themselves
i see why it's so beloved and persistent
in people's minds but then i remembered
that shredder's revenge
isn't the first time a new developer has
taken a crack at following up turtles in
time
with the 3d remake reshelled edition
hopping my malfunctioning time machine
i'll show you two turtle themed brawlers
that were lost to time forever tmnt out
of the shadows came out around the same
time
and suffered the same fate as reshelled
being that these games are no longer
available to the public and are likely
never to be sold again but i've got some
connections and i was able to get my
hands on both
how do these games fare to modern
standards are they worth bringing out of
purgatory and reviving for a new
generation
tune in after the break to find out this
video is sponsored by world of tanks
tmnt aren't the only 80s cartoon action
heroes getting a resurgence
in gaming joe which one is joe
is it that guy this guy are they all
named joe
gi joe is the code name for america's
daring highly trained special mission
force
oh it's the name of their organization
okay world of tanks on pc is free to
play with 100 million players worldwide
you can command over 550 tanks with more
than 40 battle arenas
and now for you 80s kids they're having
collaboration with the real american
hero himself
gi joe available for purchase now gi joe
breakthrough tank style and cobra battle
operational assault tank style
are designed to make two corresponding
tanks look like toys from the gi joe's
classic lineup
anyone who uses the invite code and
completes the gi joe missions will
receive free gi joe and cobra emblems to
customize their tanks
when activating the mission world of
tanks awards users one of each emblem
and then upon collecting 15 tokens
they'll be gifted an additional five of
each to fully outfit a tank if you want
to check out world of tanks in this cool
collab that they're doing
download the game today with the first
link in the description
during the registration use the invite
promo code gi joe 21
and activate in-game missions to receive
free gi joe emblems to decorate your
tanks
the code also gets you a tier 5 t14 tank
500k credits and 7 days of a premium
account
now back to the video so as we all know
turtles and time is fantastic scenery
and locations have so much variety and
the premise of spontaneous time travel
feels like such a tmnt thing to do
these guys are always teleporting around
to random crazy places by pure accident
in fact at this point they should start
getting fridge magnets from all the
alternate universes alien worlds magic
dimensions and historic time periods
they've bungled their shells into
a lot of people have a love and
admiration for this game so it made
sense to bring it back for a new
generation while the 2000s cartoon is
still relevant
so in 2009 ubisoft released turtles in
time reshelled
a fully 3d remake it's a pretty faithful
recreation of the arcade version
though it's been reskinned to distance
itself from the 80s cartoon
using updated character designs to feel
more out of the 2003 animated series
or the movie that had dropped around
that time even as the 2003 turtle shows
voice cast
the adventure isn't playing around i'm
also not sure what's up with this game
but the audio is
really loud
damn dude it peaks so loud it's all deep
fried it hurts your ears and i gotta fix
it in post
i can't tell if that's just poor audio
mixing on the developers part or a bug
or something
but no other games i've recorded in the
same session had any of that
audio stuff so if you're familiar with
the original game you'll feel right at
home
the biggest difference is that this game
takes advantage of being in full 3d
and allows you to attack in all eight
directions instead of just your left and
right which is admittedly pretty helpful
when you're getting ganged up on so you
don't need to reposition yourself
awkwardly to be able to hit anyone if
you hit someone at just the right angle
you can throw them directly at the
screen
just like a classic ironically it's not
as impressive now because it's just a 3d
model coming at the screen instead of a
2d sprite that was cleverly animated to
create the illusion of depth
these days all you got to do is just
toss the ragdoll as a camera ain't no
thing baby
though reshub might be a little too
accurate to the original in one way
you don't really have like combos it's
more so just two attack animations that
you endlessly spam at every enemy
if there's anything i would have updated
about the combat i would have added a
little bit more depth to the amount of
moves you can do since the new graphic
style would be more accommodating to
crazy fight animations
it still very much feels like an old
super nintendo game
which can be a good or bad thing
depending on what you're looking for
want something to relive the nostalgia
of your pizza eating turtle mania youth
then they got you covered want something
that holds up a bit more to modern
standards
regarding the boss characters resheld
has a really weird combination of
aesthetics
some character designs are pulled
straight from the 80s cartoon
while others feel more like they're
trying to emulate the 2003 show
the 2007 movie or just coming up with a
completely new look for the character if
they didn't really have anything to
reference from the latter
it was weird then seeing toca and razar
interacting with the cartoon cast and
it's weirder now that they've been
morphed to fit a whole other cartoon's
art design
i do dig the 2003 voice casts inclusion
though
[Applause]
tiny squid alien is the best shredder
voice by far
resheld is also faithful to the original
game's difficulty level
being that it was an arcade game it was
designed to steal quarters from small
children wearing multi-colored bandana
masks with its unavoidable traps and
cheap boss moves and
overwhelming enemy waves on my first try
i managed to make it all the way to the
final boss
but super shredder sent me and my 11
year old sister who is now 13
crying back to master splinter asking
him for more change before another kid
took the machine unfortunately in spite
of being successful commercially
timed turtles reloaded is a brand
license game and those are cursed with
finite life spans on digital markets
sure it's not so bad when you can buy a
physical copy of the game from some guy
in ohio on ebay or
dig it up in a used games bin at the
gamestop
but this game was only released
digitally on playstation store and xbox
live arcade
so when ubisoft's license to create and
distribute games based on tmnt ended
turtles and time reshelled fell onto the
same portal to nowhere as 90s mary jane
watson
never to be seen again except in stuff
made by me
but how'd i get a chance to play it well
i had help from a friend by the name of
blair
if you want to show some appreciation
for him trusting a fiend and scoundrel
like me with his psn login details
go check out his website
comicbookgames.com and because i know
it's right up your alley because you're
you
get his book about spider-man video
games it's good read
farewell turtles times magazine lost in
tokyo
you were serviceable
but you know what nothing beats the
classic and that's not going away
anytime soon
seeing is how they go hand in hand after
suffering the same fate i may as well
talk about tmnt
out of the shadows no not the movie i
mean the game
yeah the seo on that is real screwed up
now
released in 2013 from developer red fly
studios tmnt web of shadows is a game
that
somewhat kinda sorta resembles the 2012
animated series
since that was the hip new thing at the
time however it doesn't share
any voice actors from that show and has
a completely different art style
the similarity is apparent more so in
the character designs and the way
villains are utilized
like the krang being a race of aliens
instead of just a single guy
or having baxter stockman and karaya
both being controlled by shredder
or donny simping for april rath do you
think a tat would make me look tougher
absolutely mikey ink is the key to outer
toughness and hey
maybe dawn could go too and get a big
heart that says
april not listening to you
guys cool it let's go i'm not the
biggest fan of the voice acting in this
game as a lot of these voices sound a
bit
amateurish in some cases or just don't
feel like a good fit for the characters
and others
even if they are pretty talented maybe
i'm a bit biased but the only voice i
like here from the turtles themselves is
donatello
since he's my friend ben tennyson be
sure to subscribe to xavier for more
videos like this one
see you next time it's good to see that
ben's still getting work in the voice
acting industry
after that alien hero thing fell through
so what's this game about
well it just loosely adapts a story arc
from the nickelodeon cartoon
i mean incredibly loosely just the same
basic idea of shredder deciding to steal
technology from the alien race the krang
so his scientist bro baxter stockman can
use it to build him something cool
so the turtle set out to stop all three
of these different factions of bad guys
in a rip-roaring bug-filled poorly
designed adventure
you gotta love these slideshow cut
scenes because they skimped on the
budget
just looks so ugly like they just
traced over the character models really
quickly instead of drawing this art from
scratch
nothing moves in these scenes and they
reuse art for character poses constantly
you can't and say they were going for a
cool comic book style like infamous as
cutscenes
because this is just so basic and bland
the backgrounds are all
flat colors and these are just awful to
look at i also have no idea why april
o'neil is in this game because after
this weird intro sequence
you never play as her again and she
doesn't
do anything for the rest of the story
she just gets kidnapped and then you
save her via hacking minigames before i
get too much further i'd like to thank
angus from mystic for helping me get a
hold of this game
in fact thank him by checking out his
channel in the description i appreciate
your help getting the game man
now to spend the next few minutes
ripping it apart this game's a
malfunctioning
mess and i encountered constant bugs and
progression blockers
maybe if i was playing this in four
player co-op with the three other people
on earth who still own this game
we could maybe ignore the issues and
just button mash and have a good time
joking around about which ninja turtle
would have early onset diabetes from
their poor diet but no
i had to play this one alone and the
difficulty sure does not scale for
single player
let's run through all of my pain and
suffering bit by bit
the gameplay isn't fun it in fact it
sucks this game tries to emulate
arkham's free flow combat with a counter
button
but the feedback on when you're
countering isn't very good and the fight
scenes are so hectic that sometimes i
can't tell if i successfully timed my
counter right
i don't know if i blocked it or i took
the hit or what because the animations
sometimes start to overlap and cancel
each other out
you're supposed to use the kick button
to break your enemies block but
sometimes that just
doesn't work for some reason when it
does work the animations of blocking and
countering are
cool i guess but i never get the sense
that it did much but stall the enemy
instead of any real damage
the enemies are so spongy that i never
knew if i was really close to beating
them or not it was just
hectic and stressful wailing on them to
knock them down
then they stood right back up and didn't
seem mildly phased
how about a health bar or something on
them or
just anything that tells me that i'm
making progress
because nothing else indicates that even
knocking off a guy's armor or slicing
off a robot enemies mechanical limbs
didn't seem to do anything because they
just kept going and going and going
the fighting feels slow and floaty i
feel like maybe it got faster after i
bought most of the upgrades by the end
of the game
but it took a while to notice a
difference playing this game just felt
like a boring slog
and when presented with the opportunity
i found myself choosing to just
run past huge swaths of enemies because
it was just a hassle to fight and not
fun at all
if fighting in your combat driven game
isn't good then you have nothing
special moves are useless too because
it's the most awkwardly implemented
combat mechanic i've ever seen
to do a special move you need to press
the right trigger or the r2 button on
playstation
and then move the right joystick in a
direction
towards the enemy you want to hit using
the right joystick for
anything other than camera movement is
so awkward and horrible
god of war gets away with it because
that game's camera is fixed
and you don't have to move it so using
the stick to evade is fine
here you temporarily lose control of the
camera
to do your special attack the camera is
already typically clipping into walls or
being obscured by scenery
so that's just a mess to pull off and
because you're using the trigger and the
stick at the same time
your fingers are completely off the face
buttons so you just have to
stop fighting to do these moves i have
no idea who would think this was a good
idea
just do like an ultimate alliance and
have it be like trigger plus one of the
face buttons
because then you have way more control
which reminds me
reviving a downed player requires you to
press
r2 and l1 at the same time
why not l1 and r1 why not r2 and l2
why that why the most awkward possible
combination of buttons
every individual turtle carries their
own items you can get pickups like pizza
for health packs
throwing stars and grenades cause we
know how much the ninja turtles love
grenades
and that works fine for multiplayer
whoever picks it up should be the one to
use it
but in single player these items don't
transfer when you switch characters mid
gameplay
i could have stocked up on health and
weapons leonardo
gotten overwhelmed by enemies and
knocked out and then have none of that
stuff as any of the other three turtles
with no way to revive him because
reviving players costs a health pick up
except for special occasions where it
randomly doesn't for some reason
boss fights don't have health bars
either and just do like 80
unblockable attacks so you have to just
take the hit because ranged combat is
practically non-existent
thankfully there really aren't that many
bosses in the game anyway
you fight karai twice baxter stockman's
robot
and shredder twice the real difficulty
for all of these comes from just braving
the overwhelming
constant waves of enemies that all feel
just
as tough individually as the boss is
there anything i like about this game
you may ask
well i i like the designs for the
turtles this is a really decent take on
them in a realistic art style and i
wish they look more like this in the
movies instead of the 9 foot tall shreks
covered with over designed garbage
and um the way you climb up
stuff looks cool can we talk about the
bugs let's talk about the bugs there's
this part of the docks where you're
climbing around on shipping containers
but baxter stockman springs a trap where
he blocks the way he came in and a bunch
of enemies attack you while he watches
from a security camera perspective
that's fine these types of games do
things like that all the time but the
game bugged out in this spot for me
because i could still climb on the boxes
and go back over the barricade where i
came from
where i found out that they called out
half the level and i could walk out of
bounds
then i went back to the intended area to
go forward and it repeated the security
camera fight again
only this time it wouldn't end after i
beat all the enemies so i go and hack
the door twice to get through it because
this game's broken
and then the door closes behind me and
then calls out the rest of the level
so now i'm just stuck staring at a wall
i figured out i could switch
turtles to make the camera quickly
teleport over but still had this dumb
static camera filter over it and it
wouldn't go away no matter what i did
so i proceed to do the next fight scene
where i get my shell handed to me and i
get sent back to the previous area to do
the security camera part again
and it's broken in the same way every
time now
it took me like six tries to finally get
through this area
because the checkpoint was so
unforgiving and every time it had this
stupid camera filter
because that was the only way i could
progress in fact all of these
checkpoints are really
unforgiving other times i've had prompts
that wouldn't go away even after i
pressed them
i fell out of the map during the final
boss and of course the camera's just
always buggy and just sticks in walls
and i can't see anything
i read that the ps3 version i'm playing
came out almost a year after the xbox
version to iron out some of the bugs and
polish it up
so i can only imagine how broken that
port was
this is the fixed one and last because
of the silent reaper that is copyright
licensing
this game was delisted from all digital
stores everywhere in 2017.
i can't say i'm too heartbroken over the
law so that i wish more people had
gotten a chance to play it
it's not an underrated hidden gem or
anything people with like
another year or two of testing and
polishing it would have been at least
kind of mediocre but i hate that
superhero games can all become
so hard to come by after a certain time
period makes me think that i just need
to buy
any and all games featuring a comic book
character as quickly as possible before
they're gone forever like a fortnight
skin punisher no mercy unplayable
marvel heroes online gone forever any
spider-man game before the current one
ultimate alliance on next-gen deadpool
all can't be purchased digitally anymore
you have to find a disk and those are
becoming rarer by the day
for the sake of preservation this is why
emulation is a godsend
though even that has its faults because
i couldn't emulate either of these games
as long as the files for them are out
there these games can still be
appreciated forever
good or bad these games are part of tmnt
history
don't deserve to be lost forever if you
somehow find a way to play them
go ahead if you're a turtles fan
whatever you have done extremely well my
sons
you have persevered against great
challenges and hardships
i am proud of you yeah we also gave
shredder a good
beating yes that is good too
celebrate and rest now
but the battle is not over
yo donny big brains
okay there forget outdoors work fellas
[Music]
you